There’s a lot to digest in Zack Snyder’s
Justice League, from the appearance of Martian
Manhunter to Lois Lane's pregnancy test revelation.
However, there is one thing that almost instantly
became very clear from this version of the
movie, as compared to the original one finished
by Joss Whedon and released in 2017: Wonder
Woman gets her due.
SyFy Wire noted that Diana became a "lame
rom-com protagonist," nagging, bickering,
and flirting with Batman despite the way he
shoehorns Steve Trevor into a conversation
to get an emotional reaction out of her.
She became victim to gratuitous up-skirt shots
and her action scenes, oddly, were truncated.
SyFy Wire said one of her action scenes, also,
seemed
"Clearly like a Whedon reshoot created for
fan service, as it has zero to do with the
wider plot."
Thanks to the Snyder Cut, though, that view
of Wonder Woman is gone.
She now claims a front and center position
in the Justice League's battle against Steppenwolf,
showing that she was leading — with her
trademark compassion and care — the whole
time.
So, let's really get into that scene when
Wonder Woman battles Steppenwolf and cuts
off his head.
The scene takes place in Part 7, the final
confrontation between the heroes and Darkseid's
minion.
While every one of the heroes participates
in the standoff, Cyborg and the Flash's specialized
abilities mean they focus on making sure the
Unity never happens.
The plan is for Flash to whip up a charge
that will allow Cyborg to disrupt the synchronization
of the Mother Boxes.
The others — Batman, Aquaman, and Wonder
Woman — are left to deal with a Steppenwolf
who seems especially to enjoy taunting Diana,
telling her she abandoned her sisters and
bringing up her mother's death.
Superman soon enters the fray, helping both
groups.
When the plan fails, the Flash turns back
time to give everyone a second chance.
In the end, Superman takes off Steppenwolf's
horn, and Aquaman spears him.
But it's Diana who gets in the killing blow
as Superman pushes the alien menace back toward
the portal that will bring him back to Darkseid.
Diana jumps in with her sword, slicing his
head off just before he enters the Boom Tube.
This was the intended ending to Justice League
all along — and it's one of the reasons
that fans are loving this restored version
of the character.
One user posted on Twitter,
"This is easily the best movie that has ever
been made about Wonder Woman.
Her personality, culture, family, abilities,
strength, wisdom, etc.
She carries the action in the film, and they
give her a TON of screen time to showcase
her power in a way I've never seen anyone
do before."
The scene allows Diana to exhibit her fierceness
and boldness as a warrior, removing any doubt
about her abilities and bringing back a vision
of the character that should never have been
allowed to lapse, as it did in the original
Justice League.
There's no doubt that Steppenwolf is a powerful
foe, requiring the combined efforts of heroes
like Superman and Wonder Woman, despite their
own formidable strengths.
In DC Comics canon, Steppenwolf is a New God.
Diana is a demigod: her father was Zeus, and
her mother was Hippolyta of the Amazons.
In this way, they are equals.
This means that, to director Zack Snyder,
Wonder Woman killing Steppenwolf is basically
the only ending that makes any sense.
By definition, gods can't be killed, at least
not by mere mortals — even ones with mutant
powers, like Aquaman, or ones who get theirs
from the yellow sun, like Superman.
In 2019, Snyder made a post on Vero that revealed
his concept of that climactic scene in three
unfinished images.
In the caption, he noted,
"Not sure how they killed Steppenwolf in the
theatrical version of JL this was never finished
all the way but I use Gods to kill Gods."
It turns out, Snyder’s idea of Wonder Woman
seems so reasonable that it's the one many
others are embracing, too.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the DCEU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don’t miss a single one.